hey mr. james stone by rob crossley and
we are here at the xbox post media
briefing showcase we can finally get
some hands-on with all the titles that
they've been showing off lately so how
do you display from the animal yes
that's right i've been playing on
confronts revolution revolution that's
right come back after a while of just
being really underground problems in the
studio yeah that's right yeah change
studios a couple of times right it
support it was THQ right homonymous HQ
and then it was quite tech and they are
now both items over sorry ecology and to
be honest and you could you know there's
every reason to be cynical about it
everything to be next about its being
problematic the hole through the whole
project but I took him away by please
were actually so let's talk a little bit
about what you played yeah so we were
basically was an open-world choose your
own objective sort of structure so
over the city there were certain points
in the map but we had to basically go to
your son objectives like pick up files
or destroy the enemy and things like
that but what was really cool about it
was the open road structure so you could
kind of go wherever you want is and can
kind of choose however you wanted to go
there as well so there was one point in
the game where they had to pick up like
these data files and the first time I
just ran in thinking I could saw
everyone I yeah I don't know machine go
let me find and they destroyed me but
they absolutely obliterated me it was
embarrassing to watch and he's got low
as you can either playing games badly it
was terrible but the second time I
decided to go the way of the coward and
just sort of sneak in and I managed to
do about anyone seeing me so I think
it's really cool that you can choose
where you want to go and you can choose
how we want to approach our answers very
good things are because you're playing
the request to a part of the rebellions
North Korean army let's go be taken
filled out overtaken America so you are
really working with what scraps you can
ball together and they showed that up in
the trailer they revealed in it in there
that you're really the underdog yeah and
I think they did a great job snail be
kept on reminding you of that so there
was one point where you had to seize
upon this tank surrounded by military
personnel and you actually failed
terms of a story that mission failed and
everyone had to run back so it is like
your scrapping to survive basically it
does a great job reinforcing them so I
was I've ever seen the game that its
first look I think it was like a year
and a half ago when they first revealed
it it's looked a lot shinier I've gotta
say what do you think they look like
well I don't wanna be too unfair because
it's obviously friend pre-alpha or
however they call not finished these
days but it was it was a little bit
scrappy it was a little bit the frame
rate sorry yeah there was a peak
problems here in there but and I suppose
I would quite great it was quite
miserable but I roll into an impression
this gameplay you like well yeah I mean
it was this is an Orwellian described in
60 it can't be sun shining you know in
the actual price government do you kind
of leno and you're like like they 17
this right yeah oh I mean its wing until
we see ya and it's out next year for
more coverage here farm gamescom 2015
make sure you keep it in spots
you